we've been discussing the american civil
war which lasted from 1861 until 1865.
was the deadliest conflict in all of
american history in which about
620 000 americans lost their lives
we briefly went over the very end of the
war
as grant
caught up to lee at appomattox and lee
surrendered and then
confederate sympathizer and sometimes
spy john wilkes booth assassinated
american president abraham lincoln
lincoln was followed in office by andrew
johnson who will preside over
reconstruction but now that we've talked
about the progress of war from the first
fighting at fort sumter in april of 1861
to the last surrenders in november of
1865 i'd like to take just a few minutes
to contemplate what some of the bigger
issues that the civil war raises are in
american history and what impact will it
have on the future of american life
well certainly one of the most important
things if not the most important thing
to come out of the civil war is the end
of slavery
you know before
the civil war before the 1850s your
average white american who lived in say
pennsylvania or
kentucky
probably
wasn't very fond of slavery but probably
wouldn't have gone out of his or her way
to take a stand against it i think
lincoln himself was very representative
of this view in that he hated slavery
but he thought that he had no right to
interfere with it and he mostly just
wanted to make sure that slave owners
couldn't bring enslaved people out west
to take lands from what he saw as
hard-working deserving poor whites by
the end of the civil war no one could
argue that african-americans especially
in the north did not deserve citizenship
throughout the civil war
african americans proved their
importance to the nation time and time
again especially through their military
service in units like the 54th
massachusetts for example and so for the
approximately four and a half
million
enslaved people who lived in the south
they now had their freedom
and the story of what happens to these
people who have been freed with from
bondage
is perhaps the most interesting
and important story of american history
does all men are created equal mean all
men and women are created equal that is
the question that will occupy the nation
in one way or another up until the
present really another major important
takeaway from the civil war
is that the civil war represented a
movement in the united states from
a union of states
to a nation
and you can even see how abraham
lincoln's thinking on this changes over
the course of the war he starts to even
use the word
nation more and more throughout the
early part of the history of the united
states you see this balance of power
between states and between the federal
government really shifting all of the
time you see things like the
nullification crisis in the 1830s when
south carolina said we don't like this
tariff we think that as a state the
union is composed out of the consent of
the individual states and therefore the
state has the right to nullify a law it
doesn't agree with the same sort of
situation happened in 1860 over slavery
southern states believed that lincoln
would outlaw slavery and thought that it
would be more important to secede as a
group of states protecting in their
words their state's rights than to be
subject to the laws of the nation well
the civil war ends that kind of thinking
in fact you even see it from how people
write the name of this country
frequently it might have been said
before the civil war these united states
it's a group of states that are united
after the civil war it becomes
the united states
one nation
indivisible
and so
this is the moment when the federal
government
really begins to grow
you know during wartime the north had to
really organize as a nation to provide
resources for their populace and for the
soldiers and so
the president gained powers that he had
never had before and the the federal
bureaucracy itself
grew a great deal
and you're going to see this throughout
the 20th century really up until the
1970s
that the federal government in the
united states is going to have more and
more power
a third important takeaway from the
civil war
is that during the civil war the north
industrialized
to produce all of the goods
and
material
that the north needed to succeed they
built factories and railroads
and those factories and railroads and
all the rest of the impressive
engineering that went into winning the
war is then going to be turned toward
making
an industrial behemoth
in the post-war era
so
a lot of things that started during the
civil war in terms of national
industrialization really carry on in the
post-war era known as the gilded age
that help the united states become the
world's premier industrial power and
later based on that industrial power one
of the world's premier political powers
another thing that
is not often talked about with the civil
war
is the growing role of women
in the united states polity
you know in
the american civil war at first it was
very taboo for a woman of good birth to
go and become a nurse but as the war
progressed that kind of victorian
thinking believing that a woman belonged
only to a very feminine and domestic
sphere of life really had to fade away
in the face of the reality that women
needed to play a role in the war in the
north women became nurses
they helped to chair the american
sanitary commission which was one of the
key hospital groups of the time period
and in the south many women also really
took over the running of family farms
as
white men went away
white women
poorer white women for example would be
in charge of a farm themselves a white
woman who belonged to a slave-owning
family herself would then have charge of
enslaved people so women took a much
more leading role during the civil war
after the civil war some of that falls
away
in fact there's a really difficult
moment in the movement for women's
rights when
in 1870 the 15th amendment
granted african-american men the right
to vote
but not women
and so the women's movement will take
some time to regroup in the late 19th
century but the civil war like many
later wars brought women outside the
home and after the war they were not
anxious to go back there they became
involved in many charitable
organizations often known as social
housekeeping as women do more and more
things outside the home
which will eventually grow into the
women's movement of the early 20th
century and lead to women getting the
right to vote this is just a small
sampling of some of the major impacts
that the civil war had on the united
states often when we think about united
states history we think about it cutting
off at the civil war most college
courses or high school courses are
organized the u.s
before the civil war and the u.s after
the civil war because it's a really
defining moment in our nation's history
for these reasons and for many others
the united states entered the civil war
a loose union of states divided by
territory and beliefs and exited the
civil war a single nation modern
industrial peopled by an incredibly
diverse range of citizens from all over
the world in other words after the civil
war the united states will really come
into its own and that's because the
civil war was the moment when the united
states grew up the united states in 1870
looked a lot more like the year 1900
than it did the year 1860. the 13th
amendment and later the 14th and 15th
amendments ruled that people of african
descent were citizens of the united
states remember beforehand enslaved
people in the south counted for only
three-fifths of a person and that person
couldn't vote move freely or own his or
her own labor not to mention their own
life the civil war decided once and for
all that everyone born in the united
states was a united states citizen but
what citizenship really meant for
african americans for women for native
americans and immigrants even for whites
was still something that would be
hammered out through the rest of the
19th century and the 20th after the
civil war the old problems of sectional
tension and states rights were put to
rest but they were replaced by new
problems problems of modern america
industrialization
poverty immigration and so as the guns
of the civil war fell quiet the united
states embarked into a new era the
gilded age